Jake: 摊可以摊
Jake: It can be spread
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: Anything's fine
Tasha: 你觉得这么多够了吗
Tasha: Do you think this much is enough?
Katrina:  我把这个放窗台上
Katrina: I'll put this on the windowsill
Jake: 是刚到的吗
Jake: Did it just arrive?
Jake: 这是你带来的
Jake: Did you bring this?
Katrina:  就是那天海底捞送的
Katrina: It's from that day Haidilao delivered
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Tasha: 好吧再来一些吧
Tasha: Alright, let's add some more
Alice: 对我不吃
Alice: Yeah, I don't eat that
Jake: 带资进组
Jake: Bring in the funds
Tasha: 那就这么多吧也不用做很多我觉得
Tasha: That's enough, we don't need to make too much, I think
Tasha: 我就倒一一3个4个就行
Tasha: I'll just pour 3 or 4, that's enough
Tasha: 再再倒一些
Tasha: Pour some more
Lucia:  sorry按错键了
Lucia: Sorry, pressed the wrong button
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 再来一次
Lucia: Let's do it again
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm
Jake: 先删掉吧
Jake: Let's delete it first
Lucia:  sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake: 没关系挺好
Jake: No worries, it's fine
Jake: 多按了俩键问题不大
Jake: Pressed two extra buttons, no big deal
Katrina:  赠品
Katrina: A free gift
Alice: 因为我一般用的是筷子
Alice: Because I usually use chopsticks
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh
Alice: 有用过这个
Alice: Have you ever used this?
Tasha: 我觉得应该倒矿泉水
Tasha: I think we should pour some mineral water
Lucia: 呃我时间是写10
Lucia: Uh, I wrote the time as 10
Alice: 我们应该放在那个大一点的面盆里
Alice: We should put it in a bigger basin
Jake: 好的43 没没关系
Jake: Okay, 43, no problem
Tasha: 嗯这个里面我主要觉得有这个嘴好贪
Tasha: Yeah, I mainly think that this part is quite greedy
Jake: 那你们俩聊聊舞蹈
Jake: Then you two talk about dance
Jake: 在冲完牛奶之后
Jake: After finishing the milk
Lucia: 哎呦可以选一下
Lucia: Oh, we can choose a bit
Jake: 哦对对然后你们可以在这比划比划
Jake: Oh, right, you can demonstrate here
Alice: 你们家里面鸡蛋饼是比较稀的
Alice: Are the pancakes at your place usually thin?
Jake: 因为相机都给你们布好了
Jake: Because the cameras are all set up
Alice: 还是比较稠的
Alice: Or are they thicker?
Jake: 哈哈哈二楼相机没有布好
Jake: Haha, the camera on the second floor isn't set up yet
Jake: 所以没办法上去比划
Jake: So we can't go up to demonstrate
Tasha: 要顺滑的
Tasha: It needs to be smooth.
Lucia: 这里如果有美团的话地址
Lucia: If there's Meituan here, the address is...
Jake: 地址是
Jake: The address is...
Jake: 玉河区30玉河区53号你可以直接对
Jake: Yuhe District, 30 Yuhe District, No. 53, you can directly...
Tasha: 还得洗
Tasha: Still needs washing.
Alice: 你这个不也得洗吗
Alice: Doesn't that one also need washing?
Lucia: 53号
Lucia: No. 53.
Jake: 哦对就是把31改成53
Jake: Oh right, just change 31 to 53.
Jake: 因为31他找不到他要绕圈
Jake: Because if it's 31, he can't find it, he has to go in circles.
Lucia: 我的网络又开始不太给力了
Lucia: My internet is acting up again.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia:  居然是这样
Lucia: Is that why?
Lucia: 要买一个碘伏脚蹭破了
Lucia: I need to buy some iodine, my foot got scraped.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 那我可以问问这个管家
Jake: Then I can ask the housekeeper.
Lucia: 如果他有的话
Lucia: If he has it.
Katrina:  这边他们是不打扫卫生是吗
Katrina: They don't clean here, right?
Jake: 呃可以跟他们说他们就对
Jake: Uh, you can tell them, and they will, yes.
Lucia: 让他来打扫
Lucia: Ask them to clean.
Jake: 好
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 哎对京东是你要让让
Jake: Oh right, JD is... you need to...
Jake: 你什么时候去
Jake: When are you going?
Tasha: 下午他走了
Tasha: He's leaving in the afternoon.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  就是昨天我们拿快递那个
Katrina: It was like yesterday when we picked up the package.
Tasha: 他不是固定的
Tasha: He's not fixed.
Tasha: 感觉这个村
Tasha: It feels like this village...
Lucia: 我连维权有关系吗
Lucia: Is it related to my rights protection?
Katrina:  外来人员
Katrina: Outsiders.
Lucia: 但是我看对
Lucia: But I think yes.
Katrina:  随时来探望我们一下
Katrina: Come visit us anytime.
Jake: 卡住了是吗
Jake: Is it stuck?
Lucia: 我看我看
Lucia: I think, I think.
Jake: 应该没有什么
Jake: There shouldn't be anything.
Lucia: 您好像能正确使用美团
Lucia: You seem to be able to use Meituan correctly.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我觉得应该不是这个原因
Lucia: I think it shouldn't be for this reason.
Jake: 对美团的问题
Jake: Yes, Meituan's problem.
Tasha: no not at all
Tasha: No, not at all.
Jake: 这是那次海底捞的视频
Jake: This is the video from that time at Haidilao.
Tasha: 面水加多了加面面加多了加水
Tasha: Add more water to the noodles, add more noodles if there's too much water.
Katrina: 要在热水里泡
Katrina: You need to soak it in hot water.
Jake: 这么多种子
Jake: So many seeds.
Jake: 他要种什么东西
Jake: What is he planning to grow?
Katrina:  这应该是土吧
Katrina: This should be soil, right?
Katrina:  这是草莓
Katrina: These are strawberries.
Katrina:  这是赠送的樱桃萝卜
Katrina: These are complimentary cherry radishes.
Jake: 啊还能种樱桃
Jake: Oh, you can grow cherries too?
Jake: 呵呵樱桃不是种很久吗
Jake: Haha, don't cherries take a long time to grow?
Katrina:  哈哈海底捞
Katrina: Haha, Haidilao.
Katrina:  怎么海底捞的业务
Katrina: How can Haidilao's business...
Jake: 樱桃树你种过吗
Jake: Have you ever grown a cherry tree?
Katrina:  啊樱桃不是树吗
Katrina: Isn't a cherry a tree?
Tasha: 吃过算吗
Tasha: Does eating it count?
Katrina:  他怎么能给我种呢
Katrina: How can he give me something to grow?
Jake: 呵呵呵吃过差不多
Jake: Haha, eating it is about the same.
Alice: 你要的稠度吗
Alice: Do you want it this thick?
Tasha: 还要再稀一点
Tasha: It needs to be thinner.
Alice: 你得放水
Alice: You need to add water.
Jake: 点上了吗
Jake: Is it on?
Alice: 你就放这一点
Alice: Just add this much.
Lucia: nope因为飘到外星球去了
Lucia: Nope, because it floated off to another planet.
Tasha: 我又怕放多了
Tasha: I'm afraid of adding too much.
Jake: 我帮你点
Jake: I'll help you turn it on.
Alice: 没事我来了我就有点费劲
Alice: It's okay, I've got it, but it's a bit tricky.
Lucia: 奇怪啊
Lucia: That's strange.
Jake: 你用的是美团外卖是吧
Jake: You used the Meituan delivery, right?
Lucia: 就我直接点了美团的APP
Lucia: Yeah, I just ordered directly from the Meituan app.
Lucia: 然后它里面会有这个
Lucia: And it has this option.
Lucia: 我刚才里面已经搞好了但是那是一个
Lucia: I had already set it up, but it was...
Tasha: 想要不要那个搅拌器
Tasha: Do you want the blender?
Lucia: 51号是吗
Lucia: Number 51, right?
Tasha: 会不会搅拌的更顺一点
Tasha: Will it blend more smoothly?
Jake:  53
Jake: 53.
Lucia: 53 嗯
Lucia: 53? Okay.
Tasha: 感觉有颗粒感
Tasha: It feels grainy.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我是输入53吗
Lucia: Should I input 53?
Alice: 你不是要弄更多吗
Alice: Aren't you going to make more?
Lucia: 因为我看他那里还有一个
Lucia: Because I saw there's another one there
Lucia: 就是就算你输入
Lucia: Even if you input it
Lucia: 他要你选定位还是什么的
Lucia: It wants you to select a location or something
Jake: 您直接输就好了
Jake: You can just input it directly
Jake: 应该把那个53号
Jake: You should get that No. 53
Tasha: 他最后就是滑起来没有阻力的那种
Tasha: In the end, it just glides without resistance
Jake: 或者你用我这个号
Jake: Or you can use my account
Lucia: 为什么你的可以正常使用呢
Lucia: Why is yours working fine?
Alice: 蛋液应该后放
Alice: The egg liquid should be added later
Jake: 因为我是美团外卖
Jake: Because I use Meituan delivery
Jake: 美团我也不太
Jake: Meituan, I also don't...
Alice: 因为蛋液一放进去
Alice: Because once the egg liquid is added
Jake: 我也不怎么用
Jake: I don't use it much
Alice: 他把那个面给裹住了
Alice: It coats the dough
Lucia: 哦我看一下您这个
Lucia: Oh, let me take a look at yours
Jake: 我不知道美团有可能也有用
Jake: I don't know, maybe Meituan also works
Alice: 还好
Alice: It's fine
Lucia: 你的APP名字就叫美团外卖
Lucia: Your app is just called Meituan Delivery?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 下个APP我操
Lucia: Download the app, damn
Katrina:  舞蹈
Katrina: Dance
Tasha: 这么丑真的是用低筋面粉吗
Tasha: Is it really made with cake flour, it's so ugly
Tasha: 我怎么记得是用糯米粉
Tasha: I remember it being glutinous rice flour
Alice: 什么糯米粉
Alice: What glutinous rice flour
Katrina:  那我们跳舞是不是还要带上羞涩一起
Katrina: Should we also bring Shyness when we dance
Tasha: 米粉我们家好像说糯米粉
Tasha: At home, we usually use glutinous rice flour
Lucia: 我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking too
Lucia: 至少我们练的时候要大家要带上
Lucia: At least when we practice, everyone should bring it
Tasha: 感觉这种有点起劲的感觉
Tasha: It feels a bit more energetic this way
Lucia: 那会很影响
Lucia: That would really affect it
Katrina:  上再教他也没事
Katrina: We can teach him later, it's fine
Lucia: 会影响一些动作
Lucia: It will affect some moves
Katrina:  不是如果是有男生加入的话
Katrina: If a guy joins, the dance style will...
Katrina:  那个舞蹈风格就
Katrina: The dance style will change
Alice: 关系都是miss
Alice: The relationships are all...
Jake: 你可以不加入
Jake: You don't have to join
Tasha: 好奇怪啊
Tasha: That's so weird
Jake: 也可以加入都是你们说了算
Jake: Or you can join, it's up to you guys
Lucia: 要不就加入吧
Lucia: Why don't we just let him join
Katrina:  啊啊
Katrina: Ah, okay
Lucia: 让人多一点显得有气势一些显得有
Lucia: Having more people makes it look more imposing and impressive.
Katrina:  来吧一起社死吧
Katrina: Come on, let's all die of embarrassment together.
Katrina:  我找找
Katrina: Let me look for it.
Katrina:  我问问我同学他们之前跳过什么
Katrina: I'll ask my classmates what they danced to before.
Tasha: 天呐感觉很失败哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh my god, this feels like a big fail, hahaha.
Alice: 放调料了吗
Alice: Did you add the seasoning?
Tasha: 没有不是加糖吗
Tasha: No, isn't it supposed to be sugar?
Lucia: 但我觉得我这次穿来的衣服里面
Lucia: But I think among the clothes I brought this time,
Alice: 没加呢我不会做甜的
Alice: I haven't added it yet. I don't know how to make sweet stuff.
Lucia: 最适合的可能就是这条
Lucia: The best fit might be this one.
Lucia: 这条裤子和那个白色上衣了
Lucia: These pants and that white top.
Tasha: 嗯我们是站也可以直接现在加
Tasha: Hmm, we can stand and add it directly now.
Lucia: 我们也可以不那么统一
Lucia: We don't have to be so uniform either.
Tasha: 哎等一下啊这个是你想要的稠度吗
Tasha: Hey, wait a minute, is this the consistency you wanted?
Lucia: 就是服装风格差不多就可以了
Lucia: Just as long as the clothing styles are similar.
Tasha: 可以吧差不多就这样吧
Tasha: It's fine, this should be good enough.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 你放糖进去
Alice: You added sugar, right?
Jake: 或者自己做
Jake: Or make it yourself.
Alice: 直接这样放糖它会不会不融化呀
Alice: If you add sugar directly like this, won't it not dissolve?
Lucia: 节省一些预算
Lucia: Save some budget.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 好吧那就这样吧
Tasha: Alright, let's go with this then.
Alice: 你是不是得调糖水或者怎么的
Alice: Shouldn't you make sugar syrup or something?
Lucia: 我们的杯子在那边OK
Lucia: Our cups are over there, OK.
Katrina:  哎这好苦
Katrina: Hey, this is so bitter.
Jake: 也也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 自己做不一定节省预预算
Jake: Making it yourself doesn't always save budget.
Katrina:  我加了他倒进来就这么多
Katrina: I added some, but he poured in this much.
Katrina:  然后我加了这么多牛奶还是很苦
Katrina: Then I added this much milk, and it's still so bitter.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那都有谁喝咖啡啊
Lucia: So who all drinks coffee?
Lucia: 我统计一下
Lucia: I'll count.
Katrina:  我已经喝了一杯
Katrina: I've already had a cup.
Lucia: 不喝咖啡的啊
Lucia: Anyone who doesn't drink coffee?
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Lucia: 一个你喝吗
Lucia: One, are you drinking?
Jake: 来喝我也喝
Jake: I'll drink, I'm in.
Tasha: 我要喝牛奶
Tasha: I want milk.
Lucia: 呃要咖里面要不要咖啡您算上了
Lucia: Uh, do you want coffee in it or not, did you count that?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 雨轩还喝咖啡吗
Lucia: Does Yuxuan still drink coffee?
Katrina:  这密Wifi密码
Katrina: What's the Wifi password?
Jake: 哎呀挡住了挡住了挡住了
Jake: Oh no, it's blocking, it's blocking, it's blocking.
Lucia: 那现在就两个人挡住
Lucia: So now there are just two people blocking.
Jake: 对也挡住了
Jake: Yeah, also blocking.
Katrina:  Wifi密码是多少来着
Katrina: What's the Wifi password again?
Jake: 这儿
Jake: Here.
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Jake: 怎么还有指纹呢
Jake: Why is there a fingerprint?
Tasha: 来一个什么
Tasha: Have one of what?
Tasha: 你刚刚不是报名了咖啡吗
Tasha: Didn't you just sign up for coffee?
Alice: 对啊但是我又取消了
Alice: Yeah, but I canceled it.
Alice: 我现在报一下
Alice: I'll sign up now.
Lucia: 啊那你重新报名哈哈
Lucia: Oh, then sign up again, haha.
Lucia: 我们的咖啡名额减少到一个
Lucia: Our coffee slots are down to one.
Alice: 刚刚已经把我算上了总共才两个
Alice: I was already counted, so there are only two in total.
Lucia: 对对因为我我我现在不是特别困
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, because I'm not really sleepy right now.
Lucia: 所以我先不喝
Lucia: So I'll pass.
Alice: OK我只是想有个未
Alice: OK, I just wanted to have one.
Lucia: 然后雨轩刚已经喝过了
Lucia: And Yuxuan already had one.
Lucia: 那你喝什么呢
Lucia: So what will you have?
Alice: 咖啡吧
Alice: Coffee.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哎呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh, haha
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 对方撤出
Lucia: The other party withdrew.
Lucia: 撤回了一条消息又发送了
Lucia: Withdrew a message and sent it again.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 一样的是吧
Lucia: It's the same, right?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 剩下的人都喝牛奶吗
Lucia: Are the rest of the people drinking milk?
Lucia: 嗯找一个小锅
Lucia: Hmm, find a small pot.
Jake: 路亚是买好了吗
Jake: Is the lure bought?
Tasha: 就是有点多
Tasha: There are just so many.
Lucia: 啊什么啊还没呢
Lucia: Ah, what? Not yet.
Jake: 买好还买
Jake: Buy it first.
Jake: 那我先放在
Jake: Then I'll put it...
Jake: 或者我联系一下修硕
Jake: Or I can contact Shure.
Jake: 哎先联系一下收垃圾
Jake: Hey, let's contact the garbage collection first.
Lucia: 或许可以问一下他们就是民宿这边
Lucia: Maybe we can ask them about the B&B here.
Tasha: 害怕
Tasha: Scared.
Lucia: 有没有碘伏或者酒精
Lucia: Do they have iodine or alcohol?
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 因为我我刚刷了一下
Lucia: Because I just brushed it a bit.
Alice: 我能做做不了
Alice: I can or can't do it.
Lucia: 他还没有刷新出来
Lucia: It hasn't refreshed yet.
Katrina:  你们听过这个歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard this song?
Katrina:  就这个舞很简单
Katrina: This dance is very simple.
Lucia: 我好像听过让我看一眼
Lucia: I think I've heard it. Let me take a look.
Tasha: 加点面粉吧哈哈
Tasha: Add some flour, haha.
Katrina:  非常简单
Katrina: Very simple.
Katrina:  就是人家跳年会的舞
Katrina: It's a dance for annual parties.
Katrina:  这是我们之前艺术团跳着跳着玩的
Katrina: Our arts troupe used to dance it for fun.
Jake: 有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 这个是一个抖音上很火的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this a popular song on TikTok?
Lucia: 觉得我好像在哪里听过
Lucia: I feel like I've heard it somewhere.
Katrina:  钥匙
Katrina: Key.
Jake: 这是一个经典的一个
Jake: This is a classic one.
Katrina:  非常经典的
Katrina: Very classic.
Tasha: 可以吧可以
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 帮你搅吧就有点费力费手
Alice: Let me stir it for you, it's a bit tiring.
Jake: 这这是哪年
Jake: Which year is this from?
Jake: 零几年的歌还是八几年的歌呀
Jake: Is it a song from the 2000s or the 1980s?
Katrina:  嗯呵
Katrina: Hmm, yeah.
Katrina:  失恋阵线联盟
Katrina: The Lost Love Alliance.
Jake: 这可能是八几年的歌
Jake: This might be a song from the 1980s.
Katrina:  这倒是很简单
Katrina: It's really simple.
Lucia: 这个还蛮简单的
Lucia: This is quite simple.
Katrina:  就当时我们艺术团
Katrina: Back then, our arts troupe
Katrina:  男生可以跳的
Katrina: Boys could dance it too.
Katrina:  多长时间
Katrina: How long?
Katrina:  2分42 跳个2分钟
Katrina: 2 minutes 42 seconds, dance for 2 minutes.
Katrina:  就跳个1分钟就可以了
Katrina: Just dance for 1 minute, that's enough.
Lucia: 而且动作幅度也不大
Lucia: And the movements aren't big.
Lucia: 其实整体来说戴个眼镜也没什么怪
Lucia: Overall, wearing glasses doesn't look weird.
Lucia: 你看他们也戴着呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Look, they're wearing them too, haha.
Katrina:  哎对哦
Katrina: Oh right, yeah.
Alice: 喂喂好了
Katrina:  我们可以搞一点造型pose
Katrina:  一棵树哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: 可以吗可以
Tasha: 喂
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈 1棵树动作幅度这么大吗
Tasha: 我想看一下
Katrina:  搞一个那个树的头套
Tasha: 那个铜锣烧是不是
Lucia: 他现在加载出来了
Katrina:  哦还有个你你你跳舞吗
Katrina:  这不是修硕最爱的摇滚吗
Tasha: 糯米粉好吧
Tasha: 算了不学了
Katrina:  这也可以
Katrina:  当我们毕设
Tasha: 我想要换个容器
Lucia: 为什么这个
Jake: 你们
Jake: 呵呵呵
Lucia: 看起来有一点哈哈
Lucia: It looks a bit funny, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 你们想要换房间
Jake: Do you guys want to switch rooms?
Katrina:  哎呦这还有一点什么元素呢
Katrina: Oh, there's a bit of an element here.
Jake: 你你你们想要打扫房间吗
Jake: Do you, do you want to clean the room?
Tasha: 呃我只是想过筛一下
Tasha: Uh, I just want to sift through it.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 打房OK行
Jake: Cleaning the room? Okay, sure.
Katrina:  还有换队形
Katrina: And switch formations.
Lucia: 是我们要现在收拾一下扫描吗
Lucia: Are we supposed to tidy up and scan now?
Alice: 这个稠度不好过筛
Alice: This consistency isn't good for sifting.
Jake: 呃也不是
Jake: Uh, not really.
Jake: 就是可以换
Jake: But you can switch.
Tasha: 嗯也好过吧
Tasha: Hmm, it's passable.
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks good.
Jake: 可以这个哎
Jake: Yeah, this is fine.
Katrina:  这比刚刚那好看
Katrina: This looks better than before.
Alice: 呃那你试试吧
Alice: Uh, then give it a try.
Jake: 也可以啊
Jake: That works too.
Katrina:  这还有点hip Hop元素
Katrina: This has a bit of a hip hop vibe.
Jake: 晚上我们也不是晚上
Jake: At night, we are not at night
Tasha: 感觉里面有颗粒
Tasha: Feels like there are particles inside
Jake: 可能下午我们就扫一下
Jake: Maybe in the afternoon, we'll sweep a bit
Jake: 他们先帮你们扫一下
Jake: They can help you sweep first
Jake: 你们再整理一下应该就好对
Jake: You guys can tidy up a bit more, it should be fine
Tasha: 但这个这个网确实太密了
Tasha: But this net is really too dense
Lucia: 哦也可以
Lucia: Oh, that's fine
Tasha: 哇像芝士
Tasha: Wow, looks like cheese
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over
Tasha: 买的网太密了
Tasha: The net we bought is too dense
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn it
Tasha: 玛莎卡
Tasha: Mashaka
Alice: 我之前做章鱼小丸子的时候试过过筛
Alice: When I made takoyaki before, I tried sifting
Katrina:  这这怎么又是SOLO
Katrina: Why is it SOLO again
Alice: 确实不好过筛
Alice: It's really hard to sift
Katrina:  这咱就奇怪了
Katrina: That's so strange
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay
Lucia: 我们可以把那个男生的站位给他删掉
Lucia: We can remove the boys' positions
Lucia: 反正我们也没那么多人
Lucia: We don't have that many people anyway
Tasha: 稍等我一下
Tasha: Wait a moment for me
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Alice: 这做出来的差不多
Alice: This looks about right
Katrina:  偶像万万岁哦
Katrina: Long live idols
Katrina:  高中的一个
Katrina: A high school one
Tasha: 不太好过
Tasha: It's not easy to sift
Alice: 真的熟了之后没啥区别
Alice: Once it's cooked, there's no difference
Katrina:  还有女团舞
Katrina: And there's girl group dance
Alice: 就那个口感上煎饼那之类的
Alice: The texture is like that of pancakes
Katrina:  哈哈哈先开始
Katrina: Haha, let's start first
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Okay
Katrina:  嗯还有那个偶像万万岁高中跳过
Katrina: Yeah, and also that idol dance we did in high school
Alice: 因为我之前做章鱼小丸子时候过筛
Alice: When I made takoyaki before, I sifted
Katrina:  是要搞嗨一点的歌
Katrina: We need to go with more hype songs
Alice: 他不是更细
Alice: It's finer, isn't it
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Jake: 买的吗就是
Jake: Is it bought
Alice: 但是就是我那时候
Alice: But at that time
Alice: 就是跟这种稠度差不多的那个
Alice: The consistency was about the same as this
Alice: 过筛真是艰难的要死
Alice: Sifting was really a pain
Tasha: 越南过山
Tasha: Vietnam ride
Lucia: 啊他没有碘伏是吧
Lucia: Ah, he doesn't have iodine, right?
Lucia: 那我就在美团订一个
Lucia: Then I'll just order one on Meituan.
Alice: 这样吧
Alice: Okay then.
Jake: 嗯哦哦OK
Jake: Hmm, oh, oh, OK.
Katrina:  我的未来事业
Katrina: My future career.
Tasha: ok上锅
Tasha: Ok, let's start cooking.
Lucia: 53号楼
Lucia: Building 53.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 油
Alice: Oil.
Alice: 油在这
Alice: The oil is here.
Tasha: 铲子
Tasha: Spatula.
Alice: 这个能高温不能
Alice: Can this handle high heat?
Katrina:  好像广播体操
Katrina: Feels like a workout.
Tasha: 这个不能
Tasha: This one can't.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 靠这铲子怎么这么油
Tasha: Why is this spatula so oily?
Tasha: 受不了了好黏糊
Tasha: I can't stand it, it's so sticky.
Alice: 喝凉的就行
Alice: Just drink it cold.
Alice: 不用给我弄热的
Alice: No need to heat it for me.
Lucia: 呃没事反正牛奶会变成热的
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, the milk will become hot anyway.
Lucia: 所以你也可以加热牛奶
Lucia: So you can heat the milk too.
Lucia: 万一你in case you change your mind
Lucia: In case you change your mind.
Alice: 噢不不不哈哈
Alice: Oh no, no, no, haha.
Alice: 不不不不
Alice: No, no, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手啊
Jake: Hahaha, gotcha.
Tasha: 什么等等等等
Tasha: What, wait, wait, wait.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手
Jake: Hahaha, gotcha.
Tasha: 我不喝我不喝热的牛奶
Tasha: I don't drink hot milk.
Tasha: 我喝凉的就行啊
Tasha: Cold is fine for me.
Tasha: 不要放在这里啊不我不放
Tasha: Don't put it here, no, I won't.
Lucia: 不我不我不放我啊你
Lucia: No, I won't, I won't, oh you.
Lucia: 你的意思是你要用这个锅是吗
Lucia: You mean you want to use this pot, right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 啊没有没有我不用这个锅
Lucia: Oh no, no, I'm not using this pot.
Lucia: 我只是把这个在这里放一下
Lucia: I'm just putting this here for a moment.
Lucia: 然后找一个锅给它倒进去而已
Lucia: Then I'll find another pot to pour it into.
Lucia: 他这里有没有那种专门的牛奶壶
Lucia: Does he have one of those milk pots here?
Lucia: 感觉好像没有什么呃
Lucia: Seems like he doesn't, um.
Alice: 应该不会
Alice: Probably not.
Lucia: 因为如果没有的话
Lucia: Because if we don't have it
Lucia: 那个那个锅用来热牛奶就太大了
Lucia: That pot would be too big for heating milk
Lucia: 感觉一个热进去才能把他
Lucia: It feels like you could only heat up enough to
Tasha: 喝进去
Tasha: Drink it
Alice: 我洗个杯子吧
Alice: I'll wash a cup
Alice: 我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink hot
Lucia: 才能把他盖到底的感觉
Lucia: Just enough to cover the bottom
Lucia: 让我再看看
Lucia: Let me check again
Alice: 我们都是用这种杯子是吗
Alice: Are we all using these cups?
Lucia: 好像只有这种杯子耶
Lucia: Seems like we only have these cups
Alice: 哦对好的
Alice: Oh, right, okay
Alice: 那我洗一个吧
Alice: I'll wash one then
Lucia: 但你也可以用碗
Lucia: But you could also use a bowl
Alice: 好给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Sure, let's surprise the foreigners
Tasha: 第一次用这种锅
Tasha: First time using this pot
Lucia: 我觉这个锅用来热牛奶也太
Lucia: I think this pot is too big for heating milk
Lucia: 哈哈也太但是好像没有别的锅了
Lucia: Haha, but it seems like we don't have any other pot
Alice: 放油了吗
Alice: Did you add oil?
Lucia: 要不就暂且用这个吧
Lucia: Let's just use this for now
Tasha: 我没有用过这个锅煎饼
Tasha: I've never used this pot for pancakes
Alice: 啊这这油有点多
Alice: Ah, there's a bit too much oil
Tasha: 有点多是吧哈哈
Tasha: A bit too much, right? Haha
Alice: 就这样我我
Alice: Just like this, I
Tasha: 那倒出来一些吧
Tasha: Then pour some out
Alice: 你你没地方倒吧
Alice: You don't have anywhere to pour it
Alice: 你就那样吧
Alice: Just leave it
Alice: 留在锅里一点也没事
Alice: Leaving a bit in the pot is fine
Alice: 抽烟机抽烟机
Alice: Turn on the range hood